i want to thank all of you because ever
since we started this series where i
react to and review woke commercials try
to guess which products they're selling
that sort of thing
a lot of you have sent in videos through
the youtube channel
to my producer directly and some of them
are apparently so outrageous so
ridiculous that we can't even put them
on the regular
podcast on the michael knowles show so
every so often there's a real gem that
my producer says
michael you've got to sit down we're
going to roll the camera i want your
immediate raw reaction
this would be one of those occasions
without further ado let's roll the tape
this is lorenzo he fell in love with
jenna i think my favorite thing about it
is her ability just to embrace who she
is
a puppy yeah wait hold on pause
pause i'm sorry
i thought i oh man
i'm i'm just not ambitious enough in my
thoughts on how bizarre this country is
getting
i thought it was going to be like here
is lorenzo and he fell in love with
jenna
and isn't she beautiful isn't and then
she was going to turn out to be a man or
something like that
but no she doesn't turn out to be a man
she doesn't turn out to be a woman
trapped in a man's body who now dresses
like a woman
she's actually a dog trapped in a
woman's body who behaves like a dog okay
now
i've recalibrated let's continue
extremely important in my relationship
that's where a lot of like my
my love languages lie despite living
a puppy dream this canine couple have
had to deal with some harsh judgment
i definitely do get a lot of hate this
person is just absolutely
mental like out of their mind pause
it is is that hate like if i if someone
i know
comes up and is like the voices are
talking to me the voices they're calling
from the walls
and i say hey you i think you might be
absolutely mental buddy and we got to
fix that
is that it's not hateful right i'm
actually just trying to help out the guy
oh man the place we paused it she is
kissing a dog
i mean i guess some people do that i'm
not a big dog person not when the dogs
are
people and not when the dogs are dogs
let's keep going when we're in public
it can be a little bit embarrassing at
times
love don't judge i met jenna at a photo
shoot last year
we sort of clicked almost right away on
set after they met
there was one thing that jenna had to
make sure lorenzo was on board with
so i started first pretending that i was
a puppy
when i was really really little i would
ask my mom
to play with the dogs with me
so i would just be one of the dogs and
my parents always asked
when i was going to grow out of it but
i never did but pause you know one thing
the parents could have done
is told their daughter that she's not a
dog you know and just said like no
no no no i know i know that you are
supposed to know your true self but
actually you're a child and you don't
know anything
so we're going to teach you teach you
what it is
i have many thoughts on this i'm going
to i'm going to reserve
judgment though because i want to love
not judge i'm going to reserve judgment
until a little later keep going
jenna lives a puppy lifestyle and had to
make sure
lorenzo would be the right owner for all
her puppy needs
owner when i first told him about this
he didn't shy away at all
he just was like okay cool like
so what do i need to do
so puppy play really was something that
i've learned a lot
of from jenna some of her needs and
feelings
uh are very similar you know to having a
puppy which
i've never personally have have had but
uh
something that i feel that i personally
love embracing
puppy play is extremely important in my
relationship
that's where a lot of like my my love
languages
lie um i it's very important
to get a lot of praise a lot of you know
good job you're doing great you know
good girls
you pause pause so
the idea that you want to hear
compliments
is now taken as evidence that you are a
that gave me dog that you are in some
sense
actually a dog and this is these are her
needs
and this is very important you know on
its face this
isn't that i mean it's weird it's about
as weird as it gets but the the
bases of it are not that weird it's not
that weird
that this woman has sort of submissive
fantasies this is a very popular thing
among women this is why 50 shades of
grey
does very well this is why all those all
those books in the in the drugstore with
fabio
on the cover and the long hair and all
this kind of weird stuff it does well
because this is a
very widespread kind of inclination it
doesn't always lead to this
almost perfect conclusion of being so
submissive that you're actually a dog
and then this guy's reaction is kind of
interesting because you know there's
some guys who want to be a little more
aggressive
or or overbearing come on over here
coward but it kind of seems like he just
doesn't care
he's like whatever man i got this girl
she's like fairly attractive so i'm
gonna like
do whatever she wants man i don't care
man look at me i'm just a schlub so yeah
great that's that's awesome
i've given a little bit of judgment a
little i know love not judge i've given
a little judgment i'm gonna give more
later on the bond between
like that one special person like your
owner
and yeah like the day-to-day like
mannerisms of a dog
that they have you know i like to be
very carefree
i like not having you know a choice
because it makes life so much easier
like wow man that's a profound statement
i like not having a choice because it
makes life easier this
is probably where i feel the safest at
home
um it's kind of like my den it's like my
my area that i can retire to and know
that i'm
safe and you know no one can get me
the first time i saw the cage i was um
i was sort of uh shocked it was it was a
lot bigger
than i thought but once again yeah and i
saw just how happy she was
and comfortable she she really looks
good and happy and i i
think it makes a great addition to the
room
showing their puppy love on social media
has led to people questioning
their roles in the relationship some of
the
most negative comments it's probably
just people saying that i'm crazy
this person is just absolutely mental
like out of their mind
a lot of people have said like you know
are you being
held against your will is he forcing you
to do this there's a posit there
so she she's not absolutely mental right
she's
she sounds perfectly articulate here
she's just
allowing her fantasies and and
temptations to make her do crazy things
and because virtue advice or habits the
more you do it the crazier you sound
but what she's saying is a very natural
human longing which is to
get rid of free will we don't really
want to be free right we want we
we want decisions to be made for us free
will
is a kind of a a burden in some sense
because it means that there is an
objective
moral order there's an objective
physical order there's nature that we're
bound by
the woman kind of wants to be a puppy
but she's obviously not a puppy she's a
woman
and you want to transcend all of that
you want to pursue your appetites and
your desires and whatever lusts and
whatever weird kink you have
without recourse to the the way things
actually are both in this
physical world and also in the
metaphysical world and she is just
allowing this kind of natural
temptation to take her to this kind of
ridiculous extreme keep going
i know myself that i'm not hurting
anybody
i'm not in trouble i i'm just kind of
living my life
out on the internet and with that comes
a lot of judgment i try to comfort her
and let her know that
there may be a minority of people that
feel a certain negative way
about you but you still have me
that do care about you and love what you
do
we're gonna go to the park and i'm
thinking we'll get some usual shots of
you walking on a leash take some video
some photos but what if we throw a
frisbee
and you catch it in my mouth and your
mouth that's right and if you catch it
in your mouth you know what you get
right
do i get a treat yes i give it a treat
only if you catch it you ready to go yes
all right i'm ready to go sit
[Music]
good girl you want to go to the park
okay let's pause it right here so this
is obviously just
some weird sexual fetish and there are a
million sexual fetishes right if you go
on the internet
any any thing you can possibly imagine
and many things you can't even imagine i
guess like this
will be there there the line is that
there is a porn for that right there's a
porn for like every weird thing
including
i don't even really want to watch this
because it's obviously just this bizarre
voyeuristic look into these people's
sexual
kinks what these people are doing
might get their rocks off it really
might i have no doubt that at least for
this girl i don't know about the guy
this is a real sexual desire of hers
but it is without denying that you can
also say this is objectively degrading
just like lots of sexual desires because
you feel a kind of natural shame for
all sorts of things that people want to
do and so that then
now you've got this battle between what
what is my real freedom what is my real
pursuit of my
desires is it the base desire that tells
me to dress up like a puppy and have a
guy lead me around on a chain
or is it the ability to control those
passions
to i here's a dirty word repress those
base desires
and through habit cr pursue virtues
so that i have a higher level a more
rational and
more controlled and more virtuous
pursuit of
of my individual liberty what is it what
what kind of liberty are we looking at
that's that's what's at play here
and obviously they've chosen this
degrading
pursuit
so going to the dog park is obviously
one of my favorite things
when we're in public i can see how it
can be a little bit embarrassing at
times
there's weirder things out there like a
girl pretending to be a dog
isn't really the weirdest thing i think
just for a lot of people it's
it's new to see it in the way that she
does it
i don't find it weird call the police
i would say lorenz is the best owner
that i could ever ask for
he cares for me i feel like the luckiest
pup at the shelter i want to give her
that attention when she needs it make
her feel safe
and just overall see her happy and
playful
so okay i guess hopefully we've gotten
to the end here
the term owner here right is uh rankling
a lot of people
uh because her her fantasy her sexual
kink is to be
totally submissive so submissive that
you're a dog
but this key word in just the last bit
here is play
she's and he says look a girl wants to
play and pretend that she's a dog i mean
what's wrong with that
she doing it at the park lots of kids
play at the park right
children play at the park yes children
do that
but she is a grown woman and so she
shouldn't do that
the issue here is that
to these two conceptions of liberty one
posits like my conservative vision of
liberty posits that
an adult who's in full command of
himself who's past the age of consent
right who can give consent who can think
rationally who can tame down his
passions
that is liberty what that girl and her
boyfriend or
owner are doing is pursuing what i think
is now the popular conception of liberty
on the left and the right
there was an article written about this
stop it
stop it please stop it
this they told me not to look at the
article until after the video
woman who acts like a kinky puppy makes
ten thousand dollars a month on only
fans
i don't want to live on this planet
anymore i
i am in the wrong line of work uh
apparently this particular sexual fetish
is
more popular than i thought and i guess
the article does prove my thesis
that this uh conception of liberty is is
the one that is now
now embraced by our society i've never
been so sorry to be so right please send
in
am i am i really even going to request
you to do this i get my producers are
making me
please send in any other videos such as
this
that you would like me to take a look at
and
i guess we'll see you next time